You can do spot DEXes,
but they're constrained to the number of assets they can list.
If you're in DeFi and you're trading on Uniswap,
you can only trade assets that are tokenized on Ethereum.
So you can trade wBTC, you can trade ETH,
obviously wrapped SOL, there's some of that.
The further down you get on the list,
once it's no longer Ethereum-based,
you're kind of screwed.
It's so annoying to have to wrap and unwrap
and figure out exactly, you know,
what you own and how to get it out.
What really people want is the centralized exchange experience,
which is just, I'm actually trading the underlying.
That's, I think, part of the reason
why Near Intents has taken off, is it's so simple.